there's additional issue with
pornography which is not often discussed
which is that remember
guys in particular
the brain is a learning prediction
machine and if
i'm not trying to say that all
pornography is bad but there are
good data to support the idea that
if your brain learns to be aroused by
watching other people
have sex
it is not necessarily going to carry
over to the ability to get aroused when
you're one-on-one with somebody else
right
especially young kids who are consuming
a lot of pornography the brain is
learning
sexual arousal to
other people having so you're going to
program yourself into being a voice
or yeah or just create challenges in in
sexual interactions with you know with
with peers with a with a real partner
mary harrington has the three laws of
porno dynamics and the second law of
porno dynamics is the law of fap entropy
and it says that whatever you start out
wanking to will get progressively more
intense over time and i think that this
is sort of speaking to that ever ever
sort of escalating amount of um the
wildness that you need to watch in order
to get an ever decreasing
stimulus that comes back yeah and you
know here i'm i'm approaching this only
through the lens of biology right i'm
not a
you know i'm not a psychologist and i'm
certainly not um political in it in any
way at least not i have ideas about
politics but i just don't discuss them
publicly but the
but the idea here is that you know i'm
not saying
pornography as a stimulus is bad or good
what i'm saying is it
in its availability and its
extreme forms it's a very potent
stimulus
and very potent stimuli of any kind
extremely palatable food extreme
pornography
extreme experiences like bungee cord
jumping those set a threshold for
dopamine release and ana will tell you
that and i'm sure she did that the
higher the dopamine peak the bigger the
drop afterwards and it's not that you
drop to baseline you drop below baseline
so
again it's not these things aren't good
or bad they just have to be controlled
in a way because
when people are pursuing dopamine peaks
over and over and over
and they
aren't getting them typically it's
because they've been pursuing that
activity
far too often and you're saying perhaps
take a break from that and then maybe a
an ability for yourself your system to
reset right yeah yeah i mean in theory
all the things that we're talking about
with pornography could be superimposed
onto food or could be superposed onto
real sex right um
that one also has to be cautious there
right but
the cycling back and forth between
dopamine and low dopamine states
dopamine fasting as it were but maybe
just low dopamine states these are
natural rhythms
that existed in the nervous system we
had to remember what the dopaminergic
system is there for
i'll say it again i wasn't consulted the
design phase but we know as a as a
generic form of motivation in pursuit
you can imagine the human or the animal
that's hungry or thirsty it needs energy
to go pursue the thing so the idea that
you have to eat in order to get energy
that's true but you need energy in order
to get the thing to eat so our nervous
system has energy also that's dopamine
and epinephrine
yes we use glucose and glycogen etc when
we're pursuing things but the idea here
is you're pursuing something and then
either by smell or by sight you think
you're on the right track so you go down
that track and then ah there it is you
know you get some berries or you get you
know let's get prehistoric about this or
you get to kill
the prey and eat it and then it gives
you energy to continue this pursuit or
to reproduce i mean there's a reason why
humans and other animals seek out
reproduction is that every
every species but certainly humans have
two innate
desires built into them whether or not
they decide to actualize this or not is
the desire to protect young and make
more of its own species every
successful species does that even if
people don't have children in general
people care about children
because they of what they represent very
few people dislike children i mean there
are a few mutants out there that dislike
children but you always worry about
those kinds of people what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace